one issue here on campus is renaming
buildings one of our buildings is named
Coffman Union it's after one of our
former presidents and he's been accused
of racism and anti-semitism in your
opinion should we apply today is values
to the Past in renaming monuments and
buildings so as a general rule I think
not this is I think that monuments the
names on buildings this is actually a
good educational opportunity I don't
like the phrase teachable moment but
they usually are so this idea that we're
going to chip off all of the names from
old buildings I think that's foolish I
think it's actually very important as a
country for us to face up to the
problems that we've had in the past so
over at Princeton there's the Woodrow
Wilson College over Princeton and they
were talking about whether they're gonna
chip his name off the building I think
Woodrow Wilson was one of the worst
presidents we ever had I think wonder
Lawson was a terrible human being but I
think it would be important to actually
mention that way he was the president of
Princeton and I think it's important to
say listen there was a time in our
history that racism was not just a thing
it was a dominant thing there was a time
in our history where the First Amendment
was not protected there was a time in
our history
where the where the Birth of a Nation
was screened in the White House by this
guy right the movie about the glories of
the KKK it was screened in the White
House for Woodrow Wilson I think all of
that is useful and I think all of that
is good because if we don't know our
history number one we don't know how far
we've come and number two it's a
reminder of how things can go bad if we
revert back into our tribal nature so if
I don't know anything about the person
who you mentioned but if it turns out
that that person did a lot of terrible
things then I think it's important to
recognize the people are people there's
a mixed legacy usually with a lot of
these folks Thomas Jefferson was one of
the great thinkers in human history and
he held slaves and he had six children
by Sally Hemings you know this is the
that is a horrible evil thing to do but
that doesn't mean that everything that
he ever did was terrible so I think that
it's important that we recognize what's
what we've done right in the past what
we've done wrong in the past and it's a
mistake to obliterate history I just
think it's I think it's and that that's
not just my perspective that's the
perspective of Condoleezza Rice she said
the same thing
and I think she's absolutely correct